انها ثانيه بعد ظهر هنا في باريس اهلا بكم
في هذه النشره الخاصه من خاص فنكات نخصصها
لمراسم تابين اسطوره الكره المستديره بولي
بعد اربعه ايام من رحيله عن عمر بلغ 88
عاما يودع البرازيليون اليوم على مدى 24
ساعه
متواصلا نجمهم الذي اختار ان تقامر جنازته
على ارضيه ستاد فيلا بالميرو وهو ملعب
نادي سانتوس الذي فتح ابوابه للتوء امام
المعززين في هذه اللحظات لمرافقتنا خلال
هذه الساعه الرياضيه الاخباريه نسعد
باستقبال الزميل وديعه في عيني المسؤول عن
القسمه رياضي في فرانس 24
هنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه الرياضيه
معنا ايضا على هذا الحدث ايضا حمزه حلوش
المحلل الرياضي اهلا وسهلا بك
وسنستقبل عبر سكايب ايضا من المغرب ايمن
زيزيا صحفي والمحلل
الرياضي اذا همم اهلا وسهلا اذا
البرازيليون البرازيليون يلقون التحيه
الاخيره على جثمان بولي الذي يشجع على
ارضيه ملعب بيكسي اي السمكه البرتغال
البرتقاليه ويسعود 16,000
متفرج هذه هي الصور التي نراها الان قبل
ان نعود الى هذه الصور وهذا النقل المباشر
فلنتعرف معا لمن لا يعرف بليه وقد يكونون
هؤلاء قله جدا من هو هذا الاسطوره
نلاحظ معنا اذا في هذا التقرير لخالد ايه
قاسي بعدها
كان يدعى بمالك كره القدم اديسون ارنتس
بدون اسمنت والمدعوبلي ادهش الجماهير
بمهاراته فوق الميادين واهدافه الغزيره
بين الخمسينات والسبعينات ويعتبره
الكثيرون كافضل لاعب كره في التاريخ
وهو في السابع عشر من العمر عندما قاد
منتخب البرازيلي للفوز بكاس العالم عام
1958 وهو انجاز كراره مرتين في عام
1962 و 92,972 ولم يترك اللاعب البرازيلي
لقبا الا وانا له خلال مشواره رياضي مع
الناديين اللذين لعب في صفوفهما سانتوس
البرازيلي ونيويورك الامريكي وحقق ايضا
عددا من الارقام القياسيه فهو لاعب الوحيد
الذي فاز بكاس العالم ثلاث مرات وسجل
2181 هدفا في
1330 مباراه انجاز لم يعادله احد وتتويجا
لمسيرته المذهله انتخبته الفيفا كلاعب
القرن فيما ما تقول لجنه الاوليفيه
الدوليه كرياضينا وخدم بولي بلده ورياضه
خارج الملاعب ايضا فقد شغل منصب وزير
الرياضه لمده ثلاثه اعوام كما عين سفير
للامم المتحده واليونسكو اليوم يبكي
البرازيل ومحب المستديره في كل ارجاء
العالم نجما لا مثيل له
يبدو بان فلي هو الذي اختار ان يسجل في
هذا الملعب لماذا همم وما هي الرمزيه وراء
هذا هذه هذا تابين
خلال مسيرته البرازيليه اكثر من 18 عاما
بين 56 و74 قبل ان يغادر الى الولايات
المتحده ويلعب هناك هناك
لثلاثه اعوام حينها كانت كره القدم همم
جديده همم في الولايات المتحده ولكن
بالطبع في البرازيل لكره القدم مهمه جدا
لهذا سبب
الذي كان يعتبر اصبح اسطوره خاصه انه قال
المنتخب البرازيلي الى التتويج باللقب
العالمي ثلاث مرات ثلاثه ثلاثه ارقام
للمنتخب البرازيلي الاول عام 58 وكان مهم
جدا كان شاب يبلغ 11 من عمره فقط وكان همم
البرازيليين يريدون الفوز بيهز لقب بعدما
كان هزم وحتى اعتبر البرازيليون ان
الخساره خساره المنتخب البرازيلي في نهائي
مونديال 50 في البرازيل امام الاوروجواي
كانت مذله وكان هناك همم اراده باثار
والمنتخب البرازيلي بفضل بليه التي كان
يبلغ كما ذكرنا السابعه عشر من عمره
وبتسجيله هدفين في المباراه النهائيه امام
السويد قد هذا المنتخب البرازيلي الى لقبه
العلم الاول بعد ذلك توج مع البرازيل عن
62 وان لم يخذ المباريات الاخيره بسبب
الاصابه ومره الثالثه
واخيره عام 70 على ملعب استيك في مكسيكو
مع هذه المباراه النهائيه الاساسيه التي
دخلت التاريخ مباراه بين البرازيل
وايطاليا وفوز الثالث باربعه اهداف ايضا
ليه
لاعبين اخرين كتجرتينو و ااا كارلوس
البرتو قائد المنتخب البرازيلي اذا بليه
دخل بهذه الطريقه
التاريخ واصبح اسطوره ايضا لانه كان من
ناحيه له مهارات استثنائيه هو اخترع ربما
سنتحدث مع حمزه عن الناحيه الفنيه لهذا
اللاعب الاستثنائي وايضا دخل التاريخ لانه
كان موجود في كل النواحي الخاصه والعامه
كانت من الناحيه النواحي التجاريه
الاجتماعيه وايضا سياسيا لاحقا سيصبح اول
همم وزير همم له بشر سوداء يصبح وزيرا اذا
في الحكومات البرازيليه كان وزيرا لرياضه
خلال خمسه
كحلوش يعني وديع تحدث عن مهارات استث لمن
لا يفقه كثيرا في كره القدم مثل هناك
لاعبون ماهرون على مدى العصور والاجيال
وهذه اللعبه ولدت اصلا في بريطانيا وفي
الغرب فكيف للاعب ان يكتسح القلوب ويحتفظ
بلقب بالملك
في زمنه ثم بعد ذلك لما اعتزل فقال كليه
يتكلم معنا به لك قيمه فنيه كبيره هذا
اللاعب الذي تجاوز الالف هدف وهذه يعني
رقم خيالي في كره القدم سجل 1,279 هدف في
في مشواره وهو ما تعرف بها في الفيفا كما
انه صنف افضل لاعب في القرن الماضي في
فيفا يعني جوائز من ناحيه الفنيه يعني ما
كان يقوم به هذا اللاعب في الميدان نتكلم
على الاداء في 17 سنه شاركت في البطوله
عالميه في دوله اوروبيه وفاز بها وكان
تعتبر اول بطوله يعني امريكا الجنوبيه في
اوروبا يعني اول منتخب امريكي راتينيه
تحصل على البطوله في اراضي اوروبيه فعلها
في 17 سنه سجل في النهائيين يعني لما سجل
في نهائي كاس العالم ليس بشيء الهين وان
تشاهدك في ثلاث نهائيات في هذا ايضا يعني
قيمه تحسب لهذا الاسطوره
ودعنا يعني لاعب كبير نتكلم على مارادونا
ودعنا 2020 والان يعني لما يكلموا العديد
يعني المؤرخين في كره القدم او الفنيين
همم كانوا دائما ما يقولون انه هناك قطبان
في كره القدم هناك
صحيح هناك اختلاف هناك كما يصنف ان بيلي
هو الافضل وهناك من يصنف مع بعضنا لكن في
فيفا وفي احصائيه الرسميه وما الى ذلك
الجائزه افضل لاعب في القرن الماضي بحضور
مرضانه لذلك هذا اللاعب اسطوره كما اهو
اصبح واجهات تجاريه وجه اعلاميه للفيفاو
لكل يعني الاتحادات سواء الاوروبيه
الافريقيه حتى انه حضر الى دول عربيه من
بينها الجزائر حضر الى العديد من البطولات
وكان هو الوجه التجاري لاغلب بطولات التي
حدثت سابقا لقيمه فنيه كبيره جدا نتكلم
على لاعب الذي غير مفهوم المهاجم هو كان
ربما سابقا كان المهاجم ينتظر ويسجل هو
الذي خلق المهاجم رقم 9.5 يعني المهاجم
الذي يرجع الى الخلف يسقط الى وسط الميدان
ياتي بالكوره
ويسجل اهداف لذلك كان بالنسبه لهم هذا
البروفايل او هذا النوع الجديد بالنسبه
لكره القدم العالميه
وجعله متميزا بالنسبه للمهاجم الكره
لا يعرف الكره القدم يعني ما بين التاسعه
والعشره والعشره اذا ما بين
المصيبات المراسم بدات رمضان الان في
سانتوس نرى الجمهور بدا يدخل ليلقي النظر
الاخيره على جثمان بلين مذكر بليه الذي
كان توفي اا مساء الخميس في سوفاولوا في
مستشفى البرت اينشتاين
وجسمان نقل خلال الليله الماضيه همم الى
همم مدينه سانتوس على بعد 80 كيلو متر من
ساو باولو عاصمه الولايه وهناك همم اذا
الى ملعب هذا الملعب همم وكالديره حيث لعب
همم خلال 18 عاما وسط الملعب اذا وضع جسم
من همم
مغطى ولكن همم ايضا بغطاء همم ممكن ان همم
وهذا الجمهور فتحت الابواب قبل قليل همم
عند الساعه 10:00 بتوقيت المحلي اي
الثانيه بتوقيتها قبل دقائق معدوده وهؤلاء
هم همم الاول همم يتمكن من دخول المكان
نرى اطفال شيوخ سيدات على الارجح ينتظروا
لي ساعات وساعات قبل ان يتمكنوا من الدخول
فتحوا الابواب وهذه الابواب ستبقى مفتوحه
في وضع 24 ساعه 24 ساعه كامله همم كي
يتمكن جمهور البرازيلي من القاء النظره
الاخيره على بلاي قبل ان ينقل جثمان همم
غدا بعد ذلك همم
يدفن في مكان اخر علما ان الرئيس الجديد
الاولى سيكون ايضا
الحاضرين الذين سيئون الى هذا المكان
من البرازيل لا باس ان نذهب الى ضيفنا في
المغرب الصحه والمحلل الرياضي ايمن همم
المغرب تالق في المونديال الاخير واصبح
يعني محل كل التعليقات من عندكم همم كيف
ترون الى هذا الرمز الذي همم تعد همم
ايقونه الايقونه الرياضيه ليصبح ايقونه
ايضا ل همم العالم الثالث اليس كذلك يا
استاذ ايمن زيزي
انا زملاء
رمز الكره العالميه هذا ايقونه
كذلك رجل اجتماعي
يعني غير مفاهيم كره القدم
يمكن انه له فضل كبير كبير
فوق الميدان
يعني اعقل كثير لكره القدم ونعرف قصه
توليه ينقصه سينمائيه قبل ان تكون
الرياضيه كيف كيف انه راى
يبكي
لقب كاس العالم فوق الاراضي البرازيليه
انيسه 1950 وانا ذاك اتخذيني
بانه سيذهب وسياتي بهذه الكاس وبريه او
فبعد ومن ثم
[موسيقى]
في حصول البرازيل الا ثلاث ارقام لكاس
العالم همم البرازيل والمنتخب الوحيد الذي
احرز الكاس خمسه مرات وبالتالي
كبير في احراج اكثر
البرازيل بيقول لي كذلك الشخصيه سياسيه
يعني كان واجهه همم وزير للرياضه البرازيل
والاخوه انه دخل مجموعه من القرارات
الايطالي
مع كامل يمكن انه
تقولي لي ميسي في كثيرا ماديا في يعني في
مصر الرياضي يعني عندما كان يلعب ولكن
هناك مجله متخصصه في المجال الاقتصاديه
الرياضي اكدت انه في الحقبه الحاليه لو
كان مازال يمارس لهذه الحقبه كان سيجني
اموالا طائره
200 مليون دولار
تقدر
للعديد من الشركات العالميه والاشهاري
وبالتالي هو يعني شخصيات فريده من نوعها
قليلا ما نجده لاعب يتعلق
ويتال
السياسيه
حول الرياضه
هذا الطابع همم
التسويق ان صح التعبير الذي اتخذته اللعبه
ويعني همم ضلوع اللاعبين ومنهم فليفي هذه
السوق الترويجيه التي تبتعد عن الرياضه
مهم جدا في نفس الوقت يعني قبل بيليه وحتى
ايام بليه لم تكن الاموال لها همم وقع
كبير او اهميه كبيره في عالم كره القدم
بعد ذلك اصبحت الامور طبعا مختلفه على
اساس ان كره القدم اصبحت سلعه همم
الكثير من الارباح هناك الكثير من الارباح
الكثير من الاموال من التسويق رواتب
اللاعبين التي ارتفعت ايام تكون هناك همم
رواتب مرتفعه اصبحت ربما في اخر همم
مواسمي في اخر مسيرته عندما انتقل الى
الولايات المتحده اصبح يتقاضى رواتب
مرتفعه همم ولكن بظروف خاصه جدا هناك كره
كره قدم لم تكون موجوده حين في همم
الولايات المتحده كره القدم او لكره القدم
معنا اخر في الولايات المتحده هي لعبه
مختلفه لها علاقه لها باللعبه التي نعرفها
نحن همم كره القدم التي نعرفها ان تسمى
السكر في الولايات المتحده وكانت بدات
تنشا في السبعينيات وكان يح الامريكيون من
تنظيم المونديال وهذا ما حصل عام 94 وما
سيحصل ايضا من جديد بعد اربعه اعوام اذا
متحده كي يطلقوا هذه اللعبه جديده سوكر
التي يسمونها بسكر همم يعني احتاج الى
افضل لاعب حين وهو بيليه وحين بدا بليه
همم يكتب الكثير من الاموال ابتداء من
الموسم 74 ثلاثه مواسم مع نيويورك وبعد
ذلك
دخل في هذا العالم عالم التجاره عالم
التسويق وهناك الكثير من الاموال التي
بدات تصل الى عالم كره القدم ابتداء من
هذه السنوات ولكني ايضا من الناحيه الفنيه
من الناحيه الترويجيه لكره القدم تحدث عن
عن الاموال عن التجاره عن صناعه كره القدم
ولكن من الناحيه الفنيه ايضا مع بلاي بدا
كره القدم تصبح او تعتبره فنا همم ابتداء
من مونديال 58 قبل ذلك كره القدم ربما لم
منتشره بما فيه الكفايه في جميع انحاء
العالم خارج اوروبا ولكن اصبحت رياضه
عالميه وبدات اا هي الرياضه الاشهر
والاكثر متابعه في جميع انحاء العالم
ابتداءا همم من بيليه وانتشار الكره وكره
القدم كفن همم حمزه ابتداء من همم اللقب
الاول للبرازيل
كره القدم يعني تطورت ما بين فتره بيليه
وما بعدها بدخول اموال يعني انا نشوف من
جانب هذا الاموال لعبه دور ايضا ايجابي في
تطوير كره القدم لاننا نتكلم المدربين
للعمل في الميدان لابد منه وسائل متطورات
من اجل الوصول الى هذا المستوى الذي وصلته
لكره القدم لاننا قال المستوى الفني همم
على ما هو حاليا وما هو سابقا فرق كبير في
المساواه فرق كبير في الامكانيات فرخ كبير
يعني حتى في الارقام الان شوف لاعبين
حطموا ارقام ارقام مارادونا
بسبب الاموال و بسبب يعني تطور وسائل
تدريب والوسائل يعني طايقتيكيه والفنيه
تتطلب ااا يعني اموال كبيره حتى انا تعامل
مع اللاعبين من اجل انك تطور اللاعب وتوصل
الى مستوى معين مستوى الي لابد ان تكون
بوسائل يعني في كل مجالات يعني الوسائل هي
من تصنع لك دائما التفوق وهو ما اطلع يعني
قلنا المال طلبي بشكل ايجابي على كره
القدم فعلا فيه امور سلبيه يعني التدخين
في الاموال ودخول الاشارات حتى ان هنالك
بعد المباريات اصبحت تلعب من اجل اشهار
اكثر من اجل انها تلعب كره القدم من اجل
الفوز وهو الهاتف الاسماء بالنسبه
للاتحاديه كره القدم فيفا هو الفوز
بمباراه الرياضيات
تلعب على امور يعني خارجه عن كره القدم
السابقه سابقه كانت تلعب كره قدم من اجل
انه لاعبين 11 لاعب يفوز بمباراه بايطاليا
لكن مع بيليه غير في مفهوم كره القدم اصبح
المدربين يبحثون على طرق جديده من اجل
انهم يخلقوا بي لاخر
هذا سؤال نطرحه عليك وديع لان نذهب الى
المغرب همم
على كل حال ما هو اكيد هو همم هو اسم بليه
همم
طبعا مشهور وعندما دائما كان الجميع يبحث
عن جديد كان هناك مثلا الابيض همم وهو
زيكو لاعب ايضا كان نجم المنتخب البرازيلي
في افريقيا مع لاعب الغاني الذي كان يلقب
هو اسمه همم
ايوب واصبح يطلق عليه
دائما كانوا يبحثون عن طريق هوبلي جديد هل
هذا هو بيليء جديد كل ما همم نرى لاعب
برازيلي لديه مهارات همم كبيره ربما يكون
هذا هو البنيه الجديد البلي المقبل بعد
ذلك اصبح عن مارادونا جديد او الان عن
ميسي الجديد ولكن حينها كانوا دائما
يبحثون جديد وكل ما يظهر لاعب شاب في
العالم وخاصه في البرازيل ربما يقولون هذا
هو الجديد هل رونالدو
هو رونالدو البرازيلي هو الجديد الى ان
وصلنا
كان هناك علاقه خاصه ايضا
بعد التتويج المنتخب الفرنسي باللقب
العالمي عام 2018 في روسيا ااا كما هناك
تقارب همم بين رجلين اسباب ربما تشجيعيه
وبيفضل
[موسيقى]
يسجل اهداف كثيره حتى انه شارك كاس العالم
الان شارك في نسختين ومتوقع ان يشارك في
نسخه اخرى مع فرنسا ليعاد الرقم القياسي
يعني في السرعه في المهارات يعني في ذلك
في الميدان وربما يكون خليفه بالنسبه
السن ده دعونا نذهب الى المغرب بهذا
السؤال لماذا احتضنت البرازيل هذا البلد
الذي لم ااه تولد فيه كره القدم هذه الكره
وروجت لها واصبحت الرائده عالميا في هذه
اللعبه هل الامر يتوقف على بليه ام ان
الامر يتوقف على على منظومه البلد على
السيكولوجيه هذا البلد
سؤال
تنمويه همم
سوسيولوجيا كثيره اكيد انه
جديد في العالم
يعني
لا يمكن تحكم فيها او همم
في العالم
بانه هناك موهبه كبيره لدى همم الشباب في
هذا البلد يتميزون بجنيه العاليه
كان واحد منهم صحيح انا قلت له يعني
اعتبره ولكن ما اثرنيش ان هذا اللاعب يعني
كسبت كثير من الاحترام حتى من الجيل الذي
لا يشاهده الى
وهذا شيء يعني نادرا ما يمكن ان يحدث في
عالم كره القدم وفي الاعلام الرياضي يعني
كيف انه الاعلام يحترم كثيرا بلي رغم انه
لم
يعيش لماذا
كل الاخبار
ليست فقط ممارسه ليست فقط
الرياضه
لدرجه انه اليوم نتحدث عنه اللعب الذي جمع
هذه المؤهلات ميسي ومؤهلات كريستيانو
رونالدو
فقط لدينا رمزيه
والناس
ميسي وكريستيانو رونالدو ولكن كل من
الاتحاد
[موسيقى]
صحيح انه مختلف الجميل لاعبين اكثر من هذا
يعني تنافس توقف اللعب لمده طويله لعقود
ومع ذلك كان الحديد دائم في اعلان عن من
هو الافضل المستوى العصور هل هو مارادونا
هل هو ميسي وسبحان الله بري كان ينتظر ان
يتوج ميسي في كاس العالم حتى يرحل
غير ذلك لكن
على الصور التي تاتين مباشره من سانتوس
هذه المدينه وكيف يعني همم يلمس همم
المشيعون همم هذا الجسمان وهم قريبون منه
جدا هلا يعني همم هم على بعض على ما راينا
متر او مترين همم
الجثمان ونرى هنا بعض الرسميين الذين
جلسوا ربما همم افراد من العائله من عائله
ايضا يجلسون الناس العاديون
التعبير هم مروا رايناهما يمر فتحوا
الابواب كما ذكرنا عند الساعه هذه الزوجه
الاخيره لبيليه همم السيده اللباس الابيض
همم
اعتقد ان كانت الزوجه الثالثه
بعد ما كان همم له زوجه اولى همم وزوجته
ثانيه اعتقد انها زوجه الثالثه
سابقين ايضا من المنتخب البرازيلي همم
المنتخب البرازيلي الحالي همم الناس كما
راينا مروه
على 10 بتوقيت المحلي الثانيه 10 بتوقيت
همم
[موسيقى]
الناس سيستطيعون اذن دخول هذا المكان نظره
الاخيره على شومان
24 ساعه همم قبل همم ننقل الى مكان اخره
وايضا هذا بالنسبه لي همم المراسم الحاليه
الجاريه حاليا في وسط ملعب سانتوس وسط
الملعب الذي احتضن بيليه لعب فيه بيليه في
ولا 18 عاما
متتاليا بين 56 بدايه كان في السادسه عشر
من عمره وعام 74 الموسم الاخير الذي لعب
فيه مع همم المنتخب او نادي البرازيلي
سانتوس قبل ان ينتقل الى الدوري
ان يكون قريب اذا من همم حيث لعب وحيث
اشتهر بلاي عام همم كما ذكرنا عن 56 التحق
قبل الموت قبل البرازيلي بعد عام فقط من
ذلك وهو في السادسه عشر من عمره همم لعب
مع المنتخب البرازيلي المباراه الاولى ضد
الارجنتين في الكوبا امريكا هو المباراه
له دخل احتياطيا وسجل في المباراه الثانيه
بعد ايام قليله ايضا ضد الارجنتين كان
اساسيا وسجل ايضا همم في المجموعه سجل 77
هدف مع المنتخب البرازيلي ونيمار اللاعب
الشهير عدل هذا الرقم خلال المونديال
الاخير في القبائل 77 هدف مع المنتخب
البرازيلي ايضا
ربما الوحيد الذي يعني من اساطير كره
القدم التي باقافي يعني في موضوع لم يحترف
في اوروبا لان اغلب همم الاساطير مارادونا
زيدان ان يزيدان اوروبي ولكن العصر كان
مختلف ايضا همم في هذه الايام يعني لم يكن
هناك الكثير من اللاعبين من امريكا
للانديه الاوروبيه كان يحق لهم بلاعبين
اجنبيين فقط
150 هدف في
ببطوله وتحصل على رقم قياسي وافضل هداف في
البطوله كانت له يعني اتصالات من مانشستر
يونايتد
وجوفنتوس وريال مدريد
ويقال بانه حصل على عقد احترافي مع
الانترا ولكن الرئيس همم سانتوس تصل شخصيا
برئيس الانتر وقال له بان تلغي لان جماهير
سانتوس اعتراض ضد كبيره في مدينه سانتوس
على
الاحتفال الى رئيس الفيدراليه الدوليه
لكره القدم
وينتظر ايضا كما ذكرنا الرئيس الجديد
البرازيل الاولى السلام الجديده امس ههه
في هذه الرمزيه السياسيه لولا العائد من
اذن ال همم السجن العائد الى الحكم للمره
الثالثه في هذا البرازيل المنقسم على نفسه
همم وهو الذي يلقب بابي همم الامه همم
ياتي يعود فيما اب اخر لهذه الامه يرحل
همم هل هذا سيؤثر على يعني النفسيه في
البرازيل المنقسم على نفسه اكثر من اي وقت
مضاف
الرئيس السابق هو ايضا كثيرا عند وفاه
ليوم الخميس وقالوا لك ذلك الرئيس الجديد
ان يكون هناك تغيير في الحكم وايضا تغيير
سياسي همم كبير همم بين همم
البرازيل المنقسم على نفسه
قريب من السياسه سياسه الحزب الاشتراك
الاولى كان وزيرا ليه لان انت ذلك خلال
خمسه عوام وزير الرياضه وكان اول وزير
اسود يدخل همم حكومه البرازيليه وهذه نقطه
مهمه جدا من هذه الناحيه لعب دور مهم جدا
وان كان حقيقه من الناحيه السياسيه
والاجتماعيه هناك الكثير في البرازيل من
يلوم بلاي بانه لم يلعب الدور مهم جدا من
الناحيه الاجتماعيه والدفاع عن حقوق
الاقليات الدفاع عن حقوق همم
الفقراء او اصحاب البشره السوداء وان همم
كان هناك ايضا همم من بعكس ذلك همم يعتبر
انه لعب دور مهم جدا نيمار مثلا في همم في
تغريداتته الاولى عندما نعبر قال بليل
لاعب دور او اسمع صوت الفقراء اسود في
البرازيل وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا بالنسبه
للبرازيل تلك الفتره حيث كان هناك ربما ما
زالت هناك همم نوع من العنصريه في
البرازيل وايضا
تحميل ربما لعدد من الاشخاص
والبعض المجتمعات
في البرازيل ولكن صحيح
لعب هو يعتبر انه لعب دور مهم جدا وان لم
يكن مناظلا حقيقيا كما كان حال مثلا محمد
كلاي او محمد علي
الملاكم الامريكي الشهير الذي لعب دور مهم
جدا هذه الناحيه تعرض الانتقادات كثيره
بسبب عدم التزامه مثلا ضد الدكتور
الديكتاتوريه همم
الضباط همم العسكري في هذه الفتره في
البرازيل وايضا عدم التزام به في محاربه
العنصريه في البرازيل همم اذا هناك لون من
هذه الناحيه وربما في البرازيل داخل
البرازيل بالليل لم يكن يحظى بشعبيه همم
كبيره كشعبيات مثلا جارينشا اللاعب
البرازيلي الذي لعب مع بيليه في نفس الف
باللقب العالمي في نفس الفتره همم كان له
شعبيه اكبر بكثير لان غرينتشيا متى فقيرا
مات في الشارع بينما بيليه هو همم مليونير
همم
كان سيكون له نفس المصير يعني الاقدار همم
يعني ارادت هكذا
او حتى لم يكن له شهره وشعبيه عرفتنا همم
الذي توفي ايضا في في حادث في الفرن الى
واحد الذي هو ايضا كان له شهره اكبر او
شعبيه اكبر اا بين البرازيلي
لا تذهب الى ضيوفها الجميع
همم وسنعود بعدها الى السيد حمزه اذا في
المغرب بس استاذ ايمن همم حول همم يعني
هذه الحقبه
في كان فيها لاعبا اولا عبر العالم يعني
وهو محترف هل كانت لي همم صعوده يعني همم
بعض ثاني من ناحيه حركه عدم الانحياز في
هذه الفتره عندما كان حينها الصراع بين
الغرب والشرق وهل لعب دورا في هذه الرمزيه
حتى وان همم هو كعب لم يريد ان يكون ناشطا
او يعني متحدثا باسمي اي اي فريق سياسي او
اي كتله سياسيه
المستوى تواصلي المؤسساتي سياسي يعني
ميدان كره القدم
لانها ستصل الى الجميع
رئيس جديد البرازيلي ومن ضمنهم صاحب جلاله
الملك محمد السادس
همم منذ يومين الى ببرقيه التازيه وهذا
يؤكد يعني البعد او الشخصيه السياسيه لهذا
اللاعب الفتى يعني تقول بانه فعلا كان كان
وزير للشباب والرياضه في البرازيل وكما
اشار وديعه يعني
مثل يعني لا همم قليل يقوم الشخصيات
الرياضيات
[موسيقى]
في العالم جميله دي همم ان ذهبوا للسياسه
مذكور كذلك روماريو يعني المهاجم
البرازيلي الذي كذلك له طموح انه يصبح
رئيسا للبرازيل لكن لم ينجح في ذلك ولم
يكن له اجماع في افريقيا بانه المهاجم
فريق باريس سان جيرمان ليبيريز الذي اصبح
اليوم رئيس دوله في ليبيا ويعرف النجاح
يعني عندك نجاح
سياسي لكن تنظم بانك
سياسي ليس فقط داخل البرازيل ولكن
رياضيه فيها كثير من الروح الرياضيه كثير
من النقاش كثير منهم انه يعني رسم العلم
كذلك في ما يليق اخرى
ما هي الرياضيات
واقول همم اسم اسطوره ينطب همم يعني كثيرا
الى هذه اللاعبي انه ليس فقط لاعب كره
القدم وحسب لكن هو بمواهب مختلفه
ونواصل تعليق على هذه الصور التي تاتين
مباشره اذا من مدينه سانتوس البرازيليه
همم وديع همم يعني همم عندما تنتهي
الجنازه وغدا اذا همم ما الذي سيحدث بعدها
في الجثمان اين سيذهب 24
هنا في وسط ملعب سانتوس في مدينه سانتوس
فيما بعد سينقل همم اذا همم وسايمر حقيقه
همم فيما بعد الموكب همم في شوارع مدينه
سانتوس همم
سيمر امام منزل والده التي ما زالت على
قيد الحياه وهي في همم ربما تخطط المئه
عام
همم وبعدها سيدفن همم في همم دائما في
مدينه سانتوس هناك ولكن سيكون هناك حفل او
مراسم دفن همم عائليه همم غير مفتوحه امام
الجميع امام عشاق جماهير البرازيليه همم
خلافا لهذا الحفل هنا مسؤولين في نادي
سانتوس مع العلامه البيضاء والسوداء هي
علامه نادي سانتوس الفريق التي اشتهر مع
بيليه همم اشتهر بفضل
ابرز القاضي تحديدا عندما كان بلي معه كان
هداف استثنائي همم انها افضل هداف في
الدوري ساو باولو همم خلال سبعه اعوام
منها خمسه متتاليه على ما اعتقد وهنا نرى
فيفا قريا يعيش الملك باللغه البرتغاليه
بالنسبه لهم وبالنسبه لعشاق كره القدم كان
الراي كان الملك يقولون
دائما وهو ملك كره القدم كره القدم هي
ملكه الرياضات اذا ملك
الرياضه الابراج الاكثر شعبيه
عام 99 من قبل اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه
كا- رياضي القرن نتحدث عن القرن الماضي
القرض العشرين وفي العام التالي من قبل
لكره القدم لاعب كره القدم القرن همم خاصه
[موسيقى]
نتكلم على البرازيل ولاده النجوم برازيل
قدمت لي العالم ابطال عالميين لاعبين
حصلوا على كره الذهبيه رونالدو
اا ريفالدو يعني اساطير في كره القدم
روماريو ولكن يبقى دائما الملك وبيبي
استاذ ايمن من المغرب تحدثنا عن ان همم
يعني استاذ حمزه همم للتعليق على كلام
الاستاذ ايمن الذي تحدث عن رمزيات هذا
الرجل الذي همم لا يعرفه النشر ولكنه
يحبونه ويمجدونه لماذا رغم انه يعني كبير
في العمر لماذا ما الذي يجعل النشر الجديد
او الجيل الجديد او الاجيال الجديده تقدسه
رغم انها لم تراه على الملعب
لما يتكلم الناس على ابلي ربما يتكلم
القدماء الذين عاشوا
في فترات ولكن هم الان قليل نحن اا يعني
عيشنا ما ما بعد فتره بيليه ولكن كان كل
الكلام على بيليه يعني ذكر وانا صغير في
سنه التسعينات كان اي لاعب يبرز كما قال
وديع يسمى او يعني يطلق به حتى ليست في
البرازيل فقط يعني في كل اقطار العالم حتى
في البلدان العربيه اي لاعب يبرز حتى في
الساحات العموميه في الاحياء همم لاعب
نراه بنيه كبيره لان تاثيره كان كبير على
كره القدم قلت بان في البرازيل هنالك
اساطير ظهرت في كره القدم يعني رونالدينيو
رونالدو
وروماني والقدماء زيكو ولكن دائما لما
يتكلمون في البرازيل القيمه الفنيه يقولون
هنالك بيدي ثم ياتي بعده الجميع رونالدو
ظلما وصلنا في افضل المهاجم في تاريخ كره
القدم بالنسبه للكاترين ولكن لما وما
قابليش اخذ لان بيلي كما قلت في بدايه
الحصان انه لم يكن رقم تسعه مثلا كما كان
رونالدو رونالدو كان
صور ما هو اساسيه حمزه نمره سوبر على
الشاشات حتى لمن لم يعيش هذه الفتره نرى
بيري بيري يراوغ يقوم
بمراوغات خاصه استثنائيه هناك من يعتبر ان
لم ااه لم تجدد هذه المراوغات يعني بريك
وكنا اخترع كل شيء وهذه يحاول ان يقلدها
همم
العديد من الخبراء الرياضيات
لما يبحثون دائما على التقنيات يجدونها في
به يعني تعود همم في سنوات
والسبعينات ترى بانه على اشياء الان ما
زال تفعل يعني يكون هناك يا شادي بالنسبه
للتقنيات لانه هذا لاعب امتلك قيد حركيه
عجيبه يعني ليست عاديه لانه قلنا لعب كان
تقريبا كل اللاعبين في الميدان كان يتعرض
للاصابات رغم ذلك
ينهض ويقوم ويكمل الهجمه يعني كان متكامله
من جميع النوع سواء الفنيه وحتى البدنيه
وهذا ما صنع الفارق في هذه اللعب بدا في
16 او 17 سنه ثم تلاعب كاس العالم يعني
وانت في سن يسجل سالتي الى متى همم قبل
قليل لماذا في البرازيل هناك هذا العدد من
النجوم هذا العدد من اللاعبين
الاستثنائيين مهارات عاليه همم لان في
النهايه افضل اللاعبين يبداون في الشارع
يتدربون في الشارع في البرازيل هناك مساحه
كبيره جدا خاصه على الشواطئ مر على شواطئ
مثلا ريو همم
فلامنجو بوتفونجو همم الحديد همم الاطفال
يوميا يلعبون الكوره وكره القدم في
البرازيل مهمه جدا ايضا لانها اصبحت نوع
من المزيج بين كل اللاعبين همم وكل
المجتمعات المختلفه وكل الاعراق المختلفه
ونعرف ان في البرازيل هناك الكثير ايضا
همم المزيج من هذه الناحيه وهي اصبحت لاعب
شعبيه وبفضل كل ذلك اصبح البرازيل الكره
البرازيل المشهوره عبر العالم لانه هناك
الكثير من اللاعبين همم هناك العدد
وهناك ايضا همم ايضا همم المستوى والفنيات
العاديه
المهارات من العدم اليس كذلك فلنتوقف
اتحدث اذا وديع عن الساعات الاخيره او
الامنيه انه همم يحصل على الكاس همم مع
بلاده في في هذا المونديال الاخير ولكن لم
يتم ذلك لكن لنا الى الايام الاخيره من
حياه بوليف في هذا التقرير من توقيع نسيم
بن معمر
[موسيقى]
الجاري بقطر بعد تاهلهم الى الدوري ربع
النهائي من كاس العالم لكره القدم رفع
لاعبوا البرازيل هذه اللافته تكريما للعب
دوليه جوهره التاريخ الكروي البرازيلي
والذي تدهورت صحته انا ذاك بشكل كبير
صور توليه زينت واجهات عدد من البنايات
الشاهقه في الدوحه وقد عبر حينها اللاعب
الشهير عن شكره لمنظمه البطوله عن هذه
اللفته وعن امتنانه لكل من ينشغلون بصحته
حسب كلماته
الثامن عشر من ديسمبر كان يشاهدوا على
فراش المرض المباراه النهائيه بين فرنسا
والارجنتين وقد سرع حينها الى تهنئه كل من
ليونيل ميسي وكليون مبابي اللذين صنع
ملحمه كرويه خلال النهائي بعد ان شخص
الاطباء سرطان القولون لديه في سبتمبر من
عام 2021 وضع تحت مراقبه طبيه دائما قبل
ان يدخل المستشفى في نهايه نوفمبر الماضي
هو كما تضرع الملايين للسماء في الارجنتين
وفي امريكا الجنوبيه وفي انحاء العالم من
اجل نجاه النجم الراحل دييغو مارادونا في
نوفمبر من عام 2020 لم يصمت بولي كذلك
ورائه اسطوره تعبر ذاكره الملاعب
وشغف الاجيال
[موسيقى]
التي نزلت تصلنا دائما
معروض في وسط هذا الملعب خلافا لعمه الناس
الذين هم يمرون عن بعض ويكون النظره
الاخيره اذا
الابواب في الملعب فتحت عندها الساعه
10:00 بتوقيت المحلي وسيكون باستطاعه همم
جمهور ان يمر من هنا ان يدخل الملعب ولا
24 ساعه حتى الساعه 10:00 من يوم غد وايضا
في ظل هذه التغطيه المتواصله نرحب
بالزميله سحر طارق سحر همم اهلا بك همم
تابعتي الاصدقاء في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي حول هذا الحدث منذ ايامه
الاخيره في المستشفى اصلا خلال مونديال
قطر يتصدر اسم بيليه شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي منذ الاعلان عن وفاته عالم كره
القدم في حداد الملك الاسطوره افضل لاعب
في التاريخ على الاطلاق ابو اللعبه مايكل
جوردن كره القدم هي ابرز الالقاب التي
يستخدمها نجوم كره القدم حول العالم في
نعمه نجوم شباب يعتبرونه قدوه لهم مثل
رونالدو لاعب بيليه المفضل كما كان يقول
دائما بيليف اللقاءات التلفزيونيه
كريستيانو رونالدو كتب كلمه الوداع للملك
الابدي لا تكفي للتعبير عن حجم الخساره
والالم الذي يشعر به عالم كره القدم باسره
حاليا لقد كان بيليه مصدر الهام العديد من
الملايين هو مرجع امس واليوم والابد ميسي
التي هنائه بيليه بمناسبه الفوز بكاس
العالم لكن كان يقول دائما انه يفضل طريقه
رونالدو عن ميسي ميسي كلمته كانت مقتدى با
في التعزيه واكتفى بالدعاء له بالركود في
سلام ابن البرازيل نيمار بالاضافه الى
مبابي ايضا الذي تغزل بادائه بلي خلال
نهائي كاس العالم وحكيم ايضا وغيرهم
الكثيرين تحدثوا في تغريداتهم عن ارث لن
ينسى هذا بالنسبه للنجوم الشباب اما
النجوم كره القدم
النجوم الكره المستديره الذين عاشروه
وخاضوا مباريات معه او ضد ضده ايضا وصفوا
تاثره او تاثيره عليها رايموند هوتسون
لاعب كره القدم المحترف السابق نشر هذه
الرساله قالبليه هو اللاعب الذي كان يعتبر
مثلي الاعلى عندما كنت في العاشره من عمري
والذي لاعبته ضده عندما كنت في الثانيه
والعشرين والذي احببته طوال حياتك كما فعل
العالم باسره استراح في النعيم العالم
يبكي من اجلك لكنه فرح بانك بركت اللعبه
الجميله
على محترفي كره القدم ابدا على الاطلاق
باليه هو تقريبا اشهر لاعب كره قدم في
العالم اجمعوا على مر اجيال كثيره ليس فقط
بفضل احترافه ولكن ايضا بفضل مناهضته
للعنصريه ورسائل السلام التي كان يبعث بها
الرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما قال بيلي من
اعظم اللاعبين الذين لعبوا هذه اللعبه
الجميله باعتباره احد اشهر الرياضيين في
العالم فقد فهم قوه الرياضه في التقريبي
بين الناس اغلب ما يرد ايضا في تغريدات
عامه الناس خلال نعيمه هي هذه المقوله
الشهيره في عالم كره القدم كل ما يقوم به
اي لاعب حاليا بيليه قام به اولا وبليه
يتصدر الجميع دائما في هذا السياق من حيث
الارقام القياسيه هو الوحيد الذي حصل على
ثلاث كؤوس عالم سجل 1000 هدف على رغم ان
هناك بعض الشكوك او النقاشات حول العدد
لكنه بالتاكيد الوحيد الذي اوقف حربا حرب
اهليه كيف ذلك في عام
1969 عندما توجه بليم مع فريقه سانتوس
لاقامه مباراه وديه في نيجيريا الواقعه في
حرب او ال التي تغرق كانت في حرب اهليه
نجوميا بيليه ومتعته الكرويه ساهمت في وقف
الحرب مؤقتا وجوده كان كافيا ليعلن طرفاء
الحرب عن هدن لمده يومين حتى يتمكن الجميع
من مشاهده بيليه وهو يلعب مباراه او
مباراهه الاستعراضيه في لاغوس وهذا بحسب
الصحف النيجيريه والغربيه التي وصفت همم
انابيلا او التي قالت انبيليه
الدبلوماسيون والمبعوثون همم اما بقيه
التغريدات بتغريدات معي بليفه همم تتضمن
ايضا اسطوره الارجنتين مارادونا التي رحل
في اوج ازمه كوفيت في 2020
ونشروا هذا الفيديو خلال نعيه كان خلال
النهي مارادونا كنا بلي قد قال
ويتمنى ان يلعب معه كره القدم في السماء
سحر طارق شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا التلخيص
المستفيد لكل ما ورد حول هذا اللاعب
الاسطوره نشكر ضيوفنا ايضا شكرا
لسيد حمزه كحلوش المحلل الرياضي شكرا لك
وعبر سكايب نشكر ضيفنا من المغرب ايمن
زيزي الصحفي والمحلل الرياضي وشكرا لك
ايضا وديع في عيني همم المسؤول عن القسم
الرياضي 24 شكرا على كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا
لكم انتم ايضا اعزائي المشاهدين ونختم
بهذه الصور اذا المباشره من البرازيل حول
حفله هذا او مراسم اقول التابين والجنازه
المستمره لاربعين 24 ساعه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]